apreciados ciudadanos del reino unido
hoy estamos muy tristes
mucha tristeza el pueblo francés se
enteró de la muerte de su majestad la
reina isabel segunda
su sabiduría y su empatía
nos ayudaron a todos atravesar
por los altibajos de las últimas siete
décadas en este mundo y con su
fallecimiento todos sentimos un vacío
mil
millones de personas en todo el mundo
vieron de nuevo las imágenes de su
coronación
inmediatamente quedaron cautivados por
esta joven que desde entonces ya
mostraba su fuerza y su valor ese valor
de la vida marcada por la guerra y el
valor
que la hizo vivir de un siglo a otro y
llevar los valores de la libertad y la
tenacidad
sus palabras poderosas pero escasas
siempre estaban llenas de dignidad y la
hicieron un símbolo constante del reino
unido
agradecemos su profundo afecto por
francia isabelle segunda lengua dominaba
nuestro idioma amaba nuestra cultura y
toco nuestros corazones
comunismo desde su coronación ella supo
no conoció a todos nuestros presidentes
ningún otro país para el privilegio de
recibir a tantas veces como lo tuvo
francia
[Música]
en ella conocimos a un gran jefe de
estado ejemplo único de su devoción bric
por supuesto por su pueblo y fue un
aliado
muy poderoso con ella
nuestros amigos y el reino unido no sólo
disfrutado en un entendimiento cordial
sino una asociación sincera y leal
a ustedes para ustedes era su reina para
nosotros era la reina de ustedes para
todos nosotros
ella estará con nosotros para siempre
recordaremos con perpetuidad los valores
que ella siempre encarnó y promovió los
valores de la fortaleza
de moral de la democracia y de la
libertad en estos tristes momentos
enviamos nuestras sinceras condolencias
a su majestad el rey a la familia real y
al pueblo británico y a todos aquellos
que amaron a la reina y a quien les hará
una falta muy profunda estamos con
ustedes